il ya deux écoles clairement dans ce
débat il y en a une qui considère que
l'union européenne ne peut pas fournir
de résultats et qu'elle n'y arrivera
jamais et y en a une autre qui trouve
qu' il faut mutualiser les vaccins mais
qu'en l'occurrence on ne l'a pas bien
géré cette fois ci alors je voudrais
dire certains semblent penser que la
france pourrait livrer une politique
héroïque tout seul ce qui est un peu
contradictoire on nous explique qu'on
est en 1940
or quand je me souviens il y avait huit
millions de réfugiés sur les routes en
france 140 l etat s'effondrer partout
rudd
relisez les descriptions de jean moulin
j'ai pas l'impression que la france est
tout à fait dans ce niveau là je suis
étonné de ce discours catastrophiste c
break ce n'est pas glorieux comme
performance mais enfin ça n'est pas non
plus l'effondrement d'un état en afrique
en pandémie sans système de santé et
malgré tout lentement les choses se
remettent et c'est valable aussi pour
l'europe je voudrais dire simplement que
ceux qui rêvent que la france va faire
une politique autonome à cet égard n'ont
tout simplement pas regarder la carte
industrielle où est la production
française en termes de vaccins et il
faut pas oublier je veux bien discuter
de ce qui se passe ce mois cette semaine
et l'héroïque douleur de monsieur taddei
de ne pas être vaccinés mais ce qui nous
fait un projet pas pour la semaine
suivante mais pour les années qui
viennent avec un besoin qui pourrait de
plus de 10 milliards de vaccins par an
et de manière relativement finançables
et sans créer des effets d'aubaine
parce que si vous en voyez tous les
états membres en ordre dispersé pour
s'offrir des vaccins la première
conséquence ça va être de désorganiser
le marché de faire monter les prix et
donc de rendre la chose plus difficile à
terme si nous voulons un véritable
système de production de vaccins et de
traitements d'ailleurs bien énorme
avantage à mutualiser la chose au niveau
européen
[Musique]